Hi, everybody. We are taking the week off, so we thought it'd be fun to listen back to our conversation with Will Ferrell. He's hilarious. It's amazing. It was so great. He came into studio with us. We were there in person just chatting about his time on the office and more. Yeah. And listen, also wanted to let you know that Nimrods is now out on streaming. You can see us and Bobby Lee and Fred Armisen and Green Day, all from the comfort of your own home. You can watch it now on. Amazon Prime Video, Apple TV Plus, and Fandango at home. Yeah, so if you didn't make it to the theater, don't you worry. You can see us on the big screen right in your living room. All right, everyone. Please enjoy and we'll see you next week with a brand new episode of Office Ladies 6.0. Bye. I'm Jenna Fisher and I'm Angela Kinsey. We were on the Office together and we're best friends. And now we're doing the ultimate Office Lovers podcast just for you. Each week, we will dive deeper into the world of the office with exclusive interviews behind the scenes details and lots of BFF stories.
大家好。我们这周放假，所以我们觉得重温一下我们和威尔·法瑞尔的谈话会很有趣。他太搞笑了。太棒了。真的太棒了。他来到录音室和我们一起。我们当时在现场，只是聊了聊他在《办公室》的经历以及更多。是的。而且听着，还想告诉大家，《淘气包》现在已经上线流媒体了。你可以在家里的舒适环境中观看我们、鲍比·李、弗莱德·阿米森和绿日乐队的表演。你现在可以在亚马逊 Prime 视频、Apple TV Plus 和 Fandango at home 上观看了。是的，所以如果你没去剧院，别担心。你可以在客厅里的大屏幕上看到我们。好了，各位。请尽情享受吧，我们下周将带着《办公室女士 6.0》的全新一集与大家见面。再见。我是珍娜·费舍尔，我是安吉拉·金西。我们一起出演过《办公室》，我们是好朋友。现在我们正在为您制作终极的《办公室》爱 好者播客。每周，我们都会通过独家采访、幕后细节和许多闺蜜故事，更深入地探索《办公室》的世界。
We're the Office Lady 6.0. I'm very excited. Well, I'm excited. Before we get to it, you're having a super cute hair day. Oh my gosh, lady, I got my hair cut and I got it colored. And so it's like very frosh. You look saucy and frosh. Well, it's good timing too because we have a special guest today.
我们是《办公室女士 6.0》。我非常兴奋。嗯，我很兴奋。在我们开始之前，你今天的发型超级可爱。哦，天哪，女士，我剪了头发，还染了。所以看起来非常清爽。你看上去既时髦又清爽。嗯，时机也很好，因为我们今天有一位特别嘉宾。
We do. You gave me a compliment. Can I give you a compliment? Yeah. I love your sweater. I said it when you walked in and you said it was... It's like six years old. It's so cute. Because I can't take a compliment. You're like, I like your sweater. And I was like, it's really old. Well, the point is, we look really stinking cute today. And it's a good thing because someone's here. Yeah. We joshed up because we have a guest. Here today is Will Ferrell. Woo!
我们有。你夸了我。我能夸你吗？可以。我喜欢你的毛衣。你进来的时候我就说过了，你说那是……这件毛衣大概有六年了。太可爱了。因为我接受不了夸奖。你会说，我喜欢你的毛衣。而我会说，这真的很旧。好吧，重点是，我们今天看起来超级可爱。而且真巧，这里有人。是的。我们打扮了一番，因为我们有嘉宾。今天在这里的是威尔·法瑞尔。呜！
Otherwise known as DeAngelo Vickers. We thought we would do a little, I don't know, summary of Will Ferrell, but come on, you guys all know him. He was on Saturday Night Live for so many years. He was amazing. He got an Emmy nomination for being on SNL. You know, he's also been in a gazillion movies. I was in a movie with him, Blades of Glory. He's also been in Elf. Anchorman, kicking and screaming, Teledega Nights, semi-pro, stepbrothers. And he received Golden Globe nominations for his roles in the producers and Stranger Than Fiction and for producing vice. Also, He has done so many voiceovers. If you guys like the Lego movies like my kids, then you know he was Lord Business and he was hilarious.
也就是德安杰洛·维克斯。我们本来想做个小小的，我不知道，关于威尔·法瑞尔的总结，但拜托，你们都知道他。他曾在《周六夜现场》待了那么多年。他太棒了。他因参加 SNL 而获得过艾美奖提名。你知道，他还演过无数部电影。我和他一起演过一部电影，《冰刀双人组》。他还演过《精灵总动员》。《王牌播音员》、《疯狂大赛车》、《塔拉德加之夜》、《半职业选手》、《非亲兄弟》。他因在《金牌制作人》和《奇幻人生》中的角色以及制作《副总统》而获得金球奖提名。此外，他还做过很多配音。如果你和我的孩子一样喜欢《乐高大电影》，那么你就会知道他是乐高 Lord Business，而且他非常搞笑。
He might be the funniest person on the planet, Jenna. He might be one of the funniest people I've ever met. This is true. We got to spend over an hour chatting with him. We talked about his time in the office, but we also just talked about life and all kinds of things. All kinds of things. It was really fun. He's just, oh my gosh, he's everything I remembered him to be when.
他可能是地球上最搞笑的人，珍娜。他可能是我见过最搞笑的人之一。这是真的。我们和她聊了一个多小时。我们聊了他在《办公室》的时光，但也聊了生活和各种各样的事。各种各样的事。真的非常有趣。他简直是，哦天哪，他就是我记忆中的那个……
And we worked with him. So nice. So funny. But just a charming human to be around. Well, before we get to that interview, we do have a little announcement, little office ladies business. Yeah. We are taking the next two weeks off. That's right.
我们和他合作过。人很好。非常搞笑。但周围有这样一位迷人的人。好吧，在那次采访之前，我们有一个小公告，一点《办公室女士》的事务。是的。我们接下来的两周要放假。没错。
We have our kids spring break. And I'm doing a movie. Drum roll. Jenna's doing a movie. Yes, I am doing the Mean Girls movie music. for Paramount Plus written by Tina Faye. I can't wait to see it. It's going to be so great.
我们要陪孩子过春假。而且我要拍一部电影。敲鼓声。珍娜要拍一部电影。是的，我要为派拉蒙+拍摄由蒂娜·菲编剧的《贱女孩》音乐电影。我迫不及待想看了。一定会非常棒的。
You said Tim Meadows is back? Yes. Tim Meadows is in it. And, you know, I did walk hard with Tim Meadows, so I'm so excited. And he was on The Office. We love him. I play Ms. Heron. I play Katie's mom.
你说蒂姆·梅多斯回归了？对。蒂姆·梅多斯参演了。而且，你知道，我和蒂姆·梅多斯合作过《永不退缩》，所以我太兴奋了。而且他演过《办公室》。我们很喜欢他。我饰演海伦女士。我饰演凯蒂的妈妈。
I have shot one day on the movie so far, but now I have to go back to do the bulk of my work over these next couple of weeks. I mean, just based on the one day I've done so far, I could not be. more excited. So sorry, guys, but we have to hit pause on the podcast, but we'll be back in two weeks. Two weeks. All right. We're going to take a break. And then we'll be back with Will Farrell. Woohoo! I love the theme song. Thank you. Wait, your best friends. Yes.
到目前为止，我在电影里拍了一天，但接下来几周我得回去完成大部分工作。我是说，仅凭我目前拍的那一天，我就无法……更兴奋了。所以很抱歉，各位，但我们必须暂停播客，不过我们两周后会回来。两周。好的。我们要休息一下。然后我们将带着威尔·法瑞尔回来！呜呼！我喜欢主题曲。谢谢。等等，你们是好朋友。是的。
Did that, was that pre the show or during the show? During the show. You guys became friends on the show. Yes. Wow. We became besties. And maybe one of, if not the greatest takeaway of doing the show in a weird way, right? 100%. That's what Steve said. Yeah.
那是节目之前还是节目期间？节目期间。你们是在节目中认识并成为朋友的。是的。哇。我们成了闺蜜。这也许是，如果不是最棒的收获，也是以一种奇怪的方式做这个节目的最大收获，对吧？百分之百。史蒂夫也是这么说的。对。
Yeah. Yeah. Do you have a best friend, Will? From the office? Sure. That's the only context. It's only office specific. In those four episodes.
对。对。威尔，你有好朋友吗？从《办公室》里？当然。那是唯一的语境。仅限于《办公室》特定的人。在那四集里。
Who is your best friend from those four episodes? You can say Steve. You knew them before. Yeah, I guess I'll say Steve. Okay. Yeah. Since I knew him before. Okay.
在这四集里，谁是你最好的朋友？你可以说是史蒂夫。你以前就认识他们。对，我想我会说是史蒂夫。好的。对。既然我以前就认识他。好的。
Yeah. Not Creed. You and Creed aren't. and out. I didn't talk to Creed that much. No. I didn't talk to any. I, it was an interesting time. Oh. Oh. This sounds like it's going to be a hard hitting. It was an interesting time. Well, anyway. We'll get there. I bet we have some questions that crack that open. Yeah. Okay, best friend in real life. Best friend in real life. You can say their first name only if you don't want to alienate all the other friends.
对。不是克里德。你和克里德不是。在一起玩。我跟克里德没怎么聊过。不。我跟任何人都没有。我，那是一段有趣的时光。哦。哦。听起来这会是一个犀利的问题。那是一段有趣的时光。好吧，无论如何。我们会聊到的。我敢说我们有一些能打破这个局面的问题。是的。好的，现实生活中的好朋友。现实生活中的好朋友。如果你不想疏远其他朋友，你只能说出他们的名字首字母。
I'm going to say the initial J. Jay's been there for you. Yes. Through thick and thin. Thick and thin. All right. Well, here we go. In preparing for this interview, Jen and I were Googling.
我要说字母 J。J 一直在你身边。是的。无论风雨。无论风雨。好吧。那么，我们开始吧。在准备这次采访时，珍我和在用谷歌搜索。
We were looking you up on the internet. Okay. I stumbled across something on your Wikipedia page that really cracked me up. I have to read it to you. Let's see if it's, if it holds muster. Right. Okay. They list all the types of acting genres.
我们在互联网上查你。好的。我在你的维基百科页面上偶然看到了一些让我捧腹大笑的东西。我得读给你听听。看看它是不是……是不是符合标准。对。好的。他们列出了所有的表演流派。
that you are featured in. Okay. Ready, here are the genres. Improvisational comedy, sketch comedy, physical comedy, character comedy, cringe comedy, political satire, surreal humor, anti-humor, and deadpan. Wow. Does that like, that's the whole spectrum you can do. And comedy in a weird way.
你所涉足的领域。好的。准备好，这些是流派。即兴喜剧，小品喜剧，肢体喜剧，性格喜剧，尴尬喜剧，政治讽刺，超现实幽默，反幽默和面无表情。哇。这就像是，那是你能涉足的整个范围。而且以一种奇怪的方式也是喜剧。
I mean. I love cringe. Cringe comedy. And that I'm an anti-comedy. Yes. That's the one I didn't understand. What is anti-humor? I mean, is that not drama?
我是说。我喜欢尴尬。尴尬喜剧。还有我是反喜剧。是的。那是我不理解的一个。什么是反幽默？我是说，那不是戏剧吗？
I guess. Or is it something that's actually really funny that that person thought was not funny and described it as anti-comedy? I don't know. I don't know. I couldn't tell. I didn't tell if they were. I've never heard that.
我猜。或者它是某种实际上非常有趣的东西，而那个人觉得不好笑，并把它描述为反喜剧？我不知道。我不知道。我看不出来。我看不出他们是不是。我从来没听说过那个。
Yeah, I couldn't tell if they were praising you or throwing shit. On my Wikipedia page, which I obviously don't curate at all. But I'm going to now and start telling people that's my specialty. Anti-comer. Anti-humor. Look on Wikipedia. Some people think it's there. It's there.
对，我看不出他们是在赞美你还是在贬低你。在我的维基百科页面上，我显然一点也没有去维护它。但我现在要这么做了，开始告诉别人那是我的专长。反喜剧演员。反幽默。去维基百科看。有些人觉得它在那儿。它就在那儿。
Some people think it's deadpan. No, no, no. It's anti-humor. Anti-humor. Anti-humor. Will, before we get started, I did want to introduce myself to you. Jenna Fisher. Right.
有些人觉得那是面无表情。不，不，不。那是反幽默。反幽默。反幽默。威尔，在我们开始之前，我确实想向你做个自我介绍。珍娜·费舍尔。对。
We did Blades of Glory together. We did The Office. Yes. This is a little inside joke because I told a story on the podcast. I'm sure you don't remember. But early on in knowing you, every time I would run into you after we did Blades of Glory, I would say, well, hey, Jenna Fisher, we did Blades of Glory. And at one event, you finally, you took me by the hand. You said, Jenna, I know who you are.
我们一起合作过《冰刀双人组》。我们一起演过《办公室》。是的。这是一个小小的内部笑话，因为我在播客上讲了一个故事。我确信你不记得了。但在刚认识你的时候，我们在拍完《冰刀双人组》后，每次我撞见你，我都会说，哦，嘿，珍娜·费舍尔，我们一起演了《冰刀双人组》。在一次活动中，你终于，你拉起我的手。你说，珍娜，我知道你是谁。
I do. I know you. Introduce me every time. And I was like, I was like, okay. Well, you've worked with so many people. You've done so many things. I just thought maybe I would help you recall me if needed. Right.
我知道。我认识你。每次都向我介绍。而我就像，我就像，好吧。嗯，你和这么多人合作过。你做过那么多事。我只是想也许如果需要的话，我可以帮你记起我。对。
It was really a sweet moment. Okay. You're like, you don't ever have to do this. So I told her, I told her when you showed up today. I was like, you have to introduce yourself again. Was there something else we worked on too? Or were those the two main things? You know, it's so funny.
那真是一个甜蜜的时刻。好吧。你会说，你根本不用这么做。所以我告诉她，在你今天出现的时候我告诉她了。我说：你得重新自我介绍一下。我们还有合作过别的东西吗？还是说那是两件主要的事情？你知道，太搞笑了。
I felt like there was. I felt like there was too. But in Googling us, I couldn't find it. What else have we done? I thought there was something before Blades. Were you in stepbrothers? No. Oh.
我觉得好像有。我也觉得好像有。但在谷歌搜索我们时，我找不到。我们还做过什么？我以为在《冰刀》之前有什么。你演过《非亲兄弟》吗？没有。哦。
But I was in that movie with Will Arnette and Will Forte, the brother Solomon. Oh, the brother Solomon. I wasn't in that. No. I know. I went through my list of things. They weren't looking for anti-humor. No. I guess not.
但我演过那部电影，和威尔·阿奈特还有威尔·福特，所罗门兄弟。哦，所罗门兄弟。我没演那个。没有。我知道。我过了一遍我做过的事情清单。他们不是在找反幽默。没有。我想不是。
No. So you didn't get the job. The phone didn't ring. Not for that one. Not for that one. No. Here is a question we ask all of our guests. How did you get your job?
没有。所以你没得到这份工作。电话没响。那个没有。那个没有。不。这里有一个我们问所有嘉宾的问题。你是怎么找到工作的？
on the office? I got my job on the office. I had called up my peeps. Mm-hmm. My posse. My representation. No, I just thrown it out that I knew it was Steve's last year. And I just said, God, I would love to do something in that last season.
在《办公室》里？我在《办公室》找到了工作。我给我的死党们打了电话。嗯哼。我的小圈子。我的经纪人。不，我只是顺口提了一下，我知道那是史蒂夫的最后一年。我只是说，天哪，我很想在那最后一季里做点什么。
I was thinking it would be just a cameo or whatever. Right. It's up for anything. And my agent called me back and said, oh, yeah, they're three. In fact, they want to know. Greg was like, would you actually want to do a whole arc, like four shows? And I thought, yeah, why not? That'd be great.
我以为只是客串什么的。对。我什么都愿意做。我的经纪人回电话说，哦，是的，他们有三个。事实上，他们想知道。格雷格说，你真的愿意演一个完整的单元，比如四集吗？我想，行啊，为什么不呢？那太棒了。
But that's what I was alluding to when I didn't talk to many people on the set, because those last shows were emotionally charged. And you guys were all having a moment. I'm like, what am I doing here? I shouldn't be here. I was always like, oh, my God. Everyone's, here's another read-through, everyone's going to cry. And I was like, I was invited to the party and I wasn't, someone realized way after the fact,
但这就是我之前暗示的，为什么我在片场没跟很多人说话，因为最后这几集充满了情感。你们大家都在经历一个重要时刻。我想，我在这里干什么？我不该在这里。我总是觉得，哦，天哪。每个人都在，这又是一次剧本围读，每个人都要哭了。而我觉得我被邀请参加派对，然后有人在事后很久才意识到，
Will shouldn't be here. And while I had a great time and it was so fun to, you know, be a part of your guy's thing, there was a big part of me. It was like I just really felt like an outsider to no one's fault. But it was like, as you guys know, this end of an. era and we were all just in our feelings oh yeah and and you should have
威尔不该在这里。虽然我玩得很开心，能成为你们大家的事情的一部分非常有趣，但我内心很大一部分。就觉得我真的是个局外人，虽然不是任何人的错。但就像你们知道的，这是一个时代的结束，我们都沉浸在情绪中，哦是的，而且你应该
and so that's where I was like I didn't talk to a lot of people because I didn't feel like you're like I'm just going to stay out of the way I'm just going to stay out of the way because you guys are all having private moments and it was almost you know it was like sign my yearbook
所以这就是为什么我没有跟很多人说话，因为我觉得你就像，我只是要离远点。我只是要离远点，因为你们大家都在经历私人时刻，这几乎你知道，就像在我的毕业纪念册上签名一样。
end of year make sure so I have such a distinct memory when we were doing Michael's Last Dundies yes my character gets to the award for kind of a bitch and I had to go up there. And while we were doing the scene, they sort of, we had a moment where we took our lighting break or something. And I was standing next to you.
年末，确保所以我有一个非常清晰的记忆，当我们拍迈克尔的最后一次邓迪奖时，是的，我的角色获得了有点像个碧池的奖，我不得不走上去。当我们在拍那个场景时，他们有点，我们有个时刻，我们休息调整灯光什么的。我就站在你旁边。
And I just said to you, how's it going? And you said, it's great. It's great. I kind of feel like I'm doing comedy bits at a funeral sometimes. And I was like, yeah, yeah. But I'll just never forget. I was like, oh, this is going to be so hard. It's got to be so hard to come in and try to be like, like,
我只是对你说，最近怎么样？你说，很好。很好。我有时觉得自己在葬礼上表演喜剧桥段。我说，是啊，是啊。但我永远不会忘记。我想，哦，这将会非常艰难。以新人、搞笑男的身份进来，试图像这样，这一定很难。
like the new funny guy. And we're all just like, yeah. We had a really fun fan question. This question from Joanna asks, did anyone advise you not to take this role? Oh, Joanna. No.
而我们大家都觉得，是啊。我们有一个非常有趣的粉丝提问。乔安娜的这个问题问的是，有人建议你不要接这个角色吗？哦，乔安娜。没有。
No one. But I, that makes me laugh, the image of a lot of people calling me going, be careful. Don't do it. Don't do it. Hey.
没有人。但是，这让我笑出声，脑海中浮现出很多人给我打电话说，小心点。别做。别做。嘿。
You might want to. Can we talk? You might want to... Although you might be great at it because there might be some anti-humor. Yeah. No, no one advised me not to take the role. Which, you know, previously to what we were talking about, it was so fun to be there, too. You know, it was great to watch you guys all work and be a part of that as well.
你可能想要。我们能聊聊吗？你可能想要……虽然你可能很擅长，因为可能会有一些反幽默。是的。不，没有人建议我不要接这个角色。你知道的，正如我们之前所说，在那里也非常有趣。你知道，看你们所有人工作并成为其中一部分，这也是很棒的。
But it was really surreal. Yeah. From our perspective, you folded into the show. so naturally. Oh, good. Like so easily. And you were there that one episode after Steve had left. Yes.
但这真的太超现实了。是的。从我们的角度来看，你融入这个节目是如此自然。哦，太好了。就像那么轻松。而且你在史蒂夫离开后还在演那一集。是的。
You stayed for one more. And oh my gosh, we were so happy to have you there. Just as a little bit of a bridge. Yeah. Yeah. And your energy is similar to Steve's. You guys are both so nice. Right.
你多待了一集。哦，天哪，我们太高兴你能在那儿了。就当作是一座桥梁。是的。是的。而且你的能量和史蒂夫很像。你们俩都那么好。对。
And just your kindness and your humor. We were like, okay, good. But singing the rent song in the, you know, in Steve losing it. I was like, if there was a camera on me, it would be like, oh, he's not acting. Oh, he's. That Darren headlights is real. I was like, oh, my God. Okay.
而且单凭你们的善良和幽默。我们就觉得，好吧，很好。但在里唱出音乐剧《吉屋出租》的歌，你知道的，在史蒂夫崩溃的时候。我就想，如果当时有台风机对着我，那感觉就像，哦，他不是在演戏。哦，他是。那种面对车灯的茫然是真的。我就想，哦，天哪。好吧。
Yeah, right. Of course. Oh, now I get the scene. But that was really, that was so sweet and powerful. Yeah. And we were all crying. We were all looking at you because you were standing in the front of the room with Steve and we're all looking at you crying. I am just now in this moment, like putting myself
对，没错。当然。哦，现在我懂这个场景了。但那真的很，太甜蜜也很有力量。是的。而且我们都在哭。我们都看着你，因为你和史蒂夫一起站在房间的最前面，我们都看着你哭。我此刻正在
in your shoes and imagining what it must have been like for you to stand there and Steve is crying next to you. We're all crying and you're just like, hey. As DeAngelo Vickers, who has no emotional attachment, then the more takes we did than I started, it started getting to me to right. And you're like, DeAngel can't cry here. DeAngel can't cry here. He doesn't have anything invested. Here's another fan question. Okay. This is from Shell F. Had you watched the show before you came on? Yes, I had watched the show many a time and yeah, I was a fan like everyone else and just loved, you know, all the stuff everyone was doing and all the writing and the cast and just as you guys know, kind of a perfect storm of all those things put together, which is why the combination of that, and knowing Steve, but all of those things were the reason why I called up was like, gosh, would they fit me in?
设身处地为你着想，想象一下当你站在那里，史蒂夫在你旁边哭泣，这是什么感觉。我们都在哭，而你就像，嘿。作为德安杰洛·维克斯，他没有任何情感羁绊，然后我们拍的镜头越多，我开始入戏了，也开始感染到我了，对。而你会想，德安杰洛在这里不能哭。德安杰洛在这里不能哭。他没有投入任何感情。这里还有另一个粉丝提问。好的。这是来自谢尔·F的提问。在你加入之前你看过这个节目吗？是的，我看过这个节目很多次，是的，我和其他人一样是粉丝，只是喜欢，你知道，大家做的所有事情以及所有的剧本和演员阵容，正如你们所知，所有这些东西完美结合的完美风暴，这就是为什么结合了这些，而且认识史蒂夫，但所有这些都是我打电话的原因，就像，天哪，他们能把我塞进去吗？
And you guys did. And you got to go play with one of your best friends. Yeah, exactly. Yeah, exactly. And that was so fun to revisiting the episodes. I had totally forgotten that first. The first meeting between Michael and DeAngelo? Where we're at the bar and calling each other and we don't realize it.
而你们确实做到了。而且你还能去和你的一个好朋友一起玩。是的，没错。是的，没错。重温这些我完全忘掉的第一集真是太有趣了。迈克尔和德安杰洛的第一次见面？我们在酒吧里互相打电话却没认出对方。
It was like I was watching them all for the first time. It was just so fun to see how well constructed that was. And just, yeah, so stupid. Right? Yeah. Yeah. Okay, this is actually a great time for me to share this with you. I saw online a list of fan favorite quotes from DeAngelo.
就像我是第一次看它们一样。看到那是多么精妙的构思，真的非常有趣。而且，是的，太愚蠢了。对吧？是的。是的。好的，这实际上是我与你分享这个的好时机。我在网上看到了一份粉丝最喜欢的德安杰洛金句清单。
Okay. Here are some really good ones. Top of the list. Colorado, the Sunshine State. Yes. That baby could be the star of a show called Babies I don't care about. Everyone I know who skis is dead. I never touch another juggler's instruments.
好的。这里有一些非常好的。榜首。科罗拉多，阳光之州。是的。那个婴儿可以主演一个名为《我不在乎的婴儿》的节目。我认识的滑雪的人都死了。我绝不碰另一个杂技演员的道具。
And then is there an animal shelter on the way? Annie Anni Sheltow. You know what's really fun about having done those four shows is the gift that keeps on giving, which is that, you know, Greg and Paul obviously thought of that bit of the juggling without my juggling apparatus. We got more mail about that scene. Oh, my gosh. People want to hear everything you have to say about the juggling. But I remember thinking, how and why did you guys think of it this way?
然后路上有动物收容所吗？安妮安妮收容所。你知道拍那四集真正有趣的地方在于这是一份不断给予的礼物，那就是，你知道，格雷格和保罗显然想到了那个没有我的杂 juggling 设备的杂技桥段。我们收到了关于那个场景的更多邮件。哦，天哪。人们想听你对杂技的所有看法。但我记得当时我在想，你们怎么会以这种方式想到这个，为什么？
I forget what their reason was. But that was just such a genius weirdo thing that he still wants to show off his juggling. Yes. Yeah. Without any juggling. Yes. And I have now done that bit on stage, no less than. 20 times.
我忘了他们的理由是什么。但这真是一个天才般的古怪点子，他居然还想展示他的杂技。是的。是的。没有任何杂技。是的。而我现在已经在舞台上表演过这个桥段了，不下……20次。
Really? Because it's like a go-to. Because you know people will have like a little charity show or this and that. It's like, would you come do a five-minute thing or whatever you want to do? It's like ready-made. It's perfect. So I'll come out and I'll say, just introduce me as so-and-so and that I'm a juggler who's worked for 20 years down at Fisherman's Worth in San Francisco or something.
真的吗？因为这就像是拿来就用的绝招。因为你知道人们会办一个小型的慈善演出或诸如此类的活动。就像，你愿意来做个五分钟的表演或者你想做的任何事吗？这就像是现成的。太完美了。所以我会上台，然后我会说，只要把我介绍为某某某，然后说我是个在旧金山渔人码头之类的地方干了20年的杂技演员。
So I come out, I do the whole thing of like, I'm so sorry, I left. I have a little case, I'll open up and there'll be nothing in there. Oh my gosh, what's happened to them? I'm so embarrassed. All my juggling balls, I left them in my other case. I don't know what to do. And then coax the audience. And like, unless I could just do my act without them and then everyone applaud.
所以我走上台，做一整套动作，比如，真不好意思，我落下了。我有一个小箱子，我打开它，里面什么也没有。哦，天哪，它们怎么了？太尴尬了。我所有的杂 juggling 球，我都落在另一个箱子里了。我不知道该怎么办。然后哄骗观众。就像，除非我能在没有它们的情况下完成我的表演，然后大家鼓掌。
Yeah, yeah. And I do the whole thing. Do you do the balls invisibly on someone's head? Yes. Oh, my gosh. I love that. And then I'll do that. I believe that defies physics and gravity.
对，对。然后我做整套动作。你在别人头上用隐形的球做动作吗？是的。哦，天哪。我太喜欢那个了。然后我会做那个。我认为那违反了物理学和重力。
It's not a possible move. And I whisper to them like, stay as still as you can. And people will take it really seriously and they'll sit in the chair and they won't blink and I'll just throw the balls off the head. And I play the same Evan essence song. I do the whole thing. Anyway. That is amazing. It's the gift that keeps on giving.
这不是一个可能的动作。我低声对他们说：保持尽可能静止。人们会非常认真地对待它，他们会坐在椅子上，连眼睛都不眨一下，然后我就会把球从他们头上扔出去。我放着同一首伊凡塞斯乐队的歌。我做完整套动作。不管怎样。太棒了。这是一份不断给予的礼物。
One of my favorite part of it is at the end when you, it lands on the back of your. Yes. You're going to catch it there. And Kevin's like, didn't drop a single ball. Right. So that was a highlight for sure. Yeah. For me.
我最喜欢的其中一部分是在最后当你，它落在了你的背上。是的。你要在那里接住它。凯文说，一个球都没掉。对。所以这绝对是个亮点。是的。对我来说。
But also to just have to force you guys to watch it all for how many takes that I don't know. I saw myself breaking in so many takes with you. So many I would see. And also not just me, but you would see shoulders. Like the shoulders are the dead giveaway. And we were cracking up. I just wanted to know, and we had people write in, have you ever juggled? Do you know anything about juggling?
但同时也不得不强迫你们所有人看了不知多少条的拍摄。我看到自己在很多镜头里都笑场了。我看到了很多。而且不仅是我，你还能看到肩膀。就像肩膀是最大的破绽。我们在狂笑。我只是想知道，我们有人写信来问，你曾经玩过杂技吗？你懂杂技吗？
No. And I still can't juggle to this day. You can't. You're such a good fake juggle. Yeah. It didn't give me, well, it didn't like spur me on to like, maybe I should really try juggling, like, and just pretend. Like, I'm faking it pretty well. I still can't do it. I still haven't tried.
不。而且直到今天我还是不会玩杂技。你不会。你是个很棒的假杂技演员。是的。它没有给我，嗯，它没有促使我像，也许我真的应该试试杂技，比如，假装一下。就像，我假装得挺好的。我还是不会。我还没试过。
I still can't do it. Oh, you know what? We have talked about this. Your character has such a great way that he introduces himself to everyone. one in the bullpen, and we really wanted you to hear it. And then Jenna's going to share with you a second part that didn't make it in that we found in the shooting draft. Okay. Presenting DeAngelo Vickers. Hi. Hello. Hello. Hello. Thank you. How are you, sir? I'm well, sir. How are you? Can I just say I am so excited to be working here. A little bit
我还是不会。哦，你知道吗？我们讨论过这个。你的角色自我介绍的方式太棒了，对大厅里的每个人，我们真的希望你能听听。然后珍娜要和你分享第二部分，那部分没有剪进去，我们在拍摄剧本中找到了。好的。隆重介绍德安杰洛·维克斯。嗨。你好。你好。你好。谢谢。你好，先生。我很好，先生。你好吗？我能说我很高兴能在这里工作吗？一点点
About myself, I love the American Southwest, for starters. You may call them Arizona, New Mexico, Nevada, Utah. I call them heaven. I have a peanut allergy, something I live with. It's a part of me. I've learned to cope with it. What else? I'm just as comfortable at a ball game
关于我自己，首先，我喜欢美国西南部。你可以叫它们亚利桑那州、新墨西哥州、内华达州、犹他州。我称它们为天堂。我对花生过敏，这是我生活中要面对的事。这是我的一部分。我学会了接受它。还有什么？我既能适应球赛，
as I am at the opera. And there was this line where you would have said, I've never ridden a motorcycle. I've had chances. just doesn't interest me. And I love the idea that in introducing yourself to someone, you include something that does not interest you. Like, here's some stuff about me. Yeah. A little get to know you. But one thing you need to know, motorcycles do not interest me. Yeah. And so we were wondering if you had to introduce yourself in the DeAngelo Vickers style, what might you, what might you include
也能适应歌剧。这里有一句台词，你本来会说，我从未骑过摩托车。我有机会。只是不感兴趣。我喜欢这个主意，在向某人自我介绍时，你包括了一件你并不感兴趣的事。比如，这里有些关于我的事。是的。稍微了解你一下。但你需要知道的一件事是，摩托车对我没有吸引力。是的。所以我们在想，如果你必须以德安杰洛·维克斯的风格自我介绍，你可能会，你可能会把什么当作
as your non-interest? Angela's is like hardcore exercise. Oh, yeah. Like if I met a group of people I'd never met before. I might say, hi, my name is Angela. I grew up overseas. I like hummingbirds. I am not interested in anyone yelling at me when I exercise. Okay. Yeah. I would probably say, hi, I'm Will. I'm from Orange County. I do enjoy vigorous exercise, but I have no interest in skydiving. Don't talk to me about skydiving. Did you? Do it? No. I've never done it. No. No, I don't want to do it. No. I don't. Yeah. No. So if you were offered a film. Right. Or a project. Right. That involved a skydiving moment. You would say hard pass. That's going to be a stunt person.
你的不感兴趣？安吉拉的是像核心锻炼。哦，是的。就像如果我遇到一群从未见过的人。我可能会说，嗨，我叫安吉拉。我在海外长大。我喜欢蜂鸟。我对任何人对我在锻炼时对我大喊大叫不感兴趣。好的。是的。我可能会说，嗨，我是威尔。我来自奥兰治县。我确实喜欢剧烈运动，但我对跳伞没有任何兴趣。不要跟我谈论跳伞。你跳过吗？去过吗？没有。我从来没去过。不。不，我不想去。不。我不想。是的。所以如果你获得了一部电影的邀约。对。或者一个项目。对。涉及跳伞的时刻。你会说坚决拒绝。那得是个特技替身。
That's going to definitely be a stunt person. You're going to need to find someone that looks just like me. Yeah. And have them fall from the sky because I'm not doing it. Because even if I really got talked into it because I don't know if you have you guys had things where you're like at first you were like, no way, hard pass. And then. it's really safe, want to do it this way, da, da, da, da. And you're like, okay, I can't. I don't know if I could look Viveka in the eye and be like, I'm just, honey, I'm going to do this skydiving thing. It's going to be totally cool. Your wife would be like, yeah, she's going to be like, really?
那绝对得是个特技替身。你需要找一个长得跟我一模一样的人。对。让他们从天而降，因为我才不干。因为即使我真的被说服了，因为我不知道你们有没有过这样的经历，一开始你们会觉得，没门，坚决拒绝。然后。真的很安全，想这么做，哒，哒，哒，哒。然后你会想，好吧，我不能。我不知道我能不能直视薇薇卡的眼睛，说，我只是，亲爱的，我要去玩这个跳伞了。这会完全很酷的。你妻子会说，对，她会说，真的吗？
Is it that essential? I'm like, you're right. Yeah. They can get someone else. Yeah. But you have done a lot of stuff. I've done a lot of things that later I was like, why did I? Yeah.
有那么重要吗？我就想，你说得对。是的。他们可以找别人。是的。但你确实做过很多事。我做过很多事，后来我想，我为什么要做？是的。
Yeah. Like I did a, I was out in the wilderness with Bear Grills on the Bear Grills show and I was hanging from a helicopter. I saw that. Twice. I saw that. And later I was like, I thought, I didn't need to do that. Yeah. But I got wrapped up in trying to get Bear Grills to like me.
是的。就像我做过，我和贝尔·格里尔斯一起在荒野中参加贝尔·格里尔斯的节目，我挂在直升机上。我看到了。两次。我看到了。后来我想，我想，我不需要做那个。是的。但我陷入了试图让贝尔·格里尔斯喜欢我的怪圈。
Wow. I just watched the movie downhill because I have recently become sort of a skiing fanatic. I just started skiing. in my life during the pandemic. I'm slightly upset. I'm leaving today after this interview to go to Utah to ski. This is just so wild to me. So you're taking it on right now in life.
哇。我刚看了电影《滑雪奇缘》，因为我最近成了某种滑雪狂热分子。我刚开始滑雪。在疫情期间的生活中。我有点心烦。我今天采访结束后就要去犹他州滑雪。这对我来说太疯狂了。所以你现在生活中才开始学。
Yes. I learned how to ski, put skis on my legs for the first time when I was 46. And I'm turning 49 this year. Because most people learn at an early age. Yes. I grew up in Missouri. No skiing there. Not even one, not even like a little bunny hill?
是的。我学会滑雪，第一次把滑雪板穿在腿上是在我46岁的时候。我今年快49岁了。因为大多数人很小的时候就学会了。是的。我在密苏里州长大。那里没有滑雪。连一个，哪怕是一个小小的小土坡都没有？
You know what? I should say there is a place where you can ski. But I mean, come on. Right. Come on. Let's be honest. It's not really. Yeah. No. skiing. Yeah. I watch downhill. Right. Are you skiing? Is that you? I'm skiing. Yeah. You're so good. I'm not skiing where I fall and do the fall. Right. There's a fall part, right? Yeah. Are we cutting to you at the end when you're already on the ground? After I've hit my head. Yes, yes. On the thing. Yeah. Right.
你知道吗？我得说确实有一个你可以滑雪的地方。但是，拜托。对吧。拜托。老实说。那其实不是。是的。不。滑雪。是的。我看了《滑雪奇缘》。对。你在滑雪吗？那是你吗？我在滑雪。对。你太棒了。我不是那种滑倒并摔倒的滑雪。对。有个摔倒的部分，对吧？是的。我们最后会切到你已经在地上的时候吗？在我撞到头之后。是的，是的。在那个东西上。对。
That was me acting after I hit my head. Yes. It was very good. I'm going to add that to your Wikipedia. Injury comedy. Yeah, injury comedy. Comedy. Which is, again, under the category of anti-humor.
那是我撞到头之后的演技。是的。非常棒。我要把它加到你的维基百科里。受伤喜剧。对，受伤喜剧。喜剧。这又属于反幽默的范畴。
It is. I think that falls. Yeah. But no, all that other skiing. Is you. That's me. But Julia Louis Dreyfus, she's an excellent skier. She was very good.
确实。我觉得属于。对。但是不，所有其他滑雪。都是你。那是我。但朱莉娅·路易斯-德利法斯，她是个极好的滑雪者。她非常擅长。
in the film as well. She can do the moguls and everything. I can't quite do the moguls. No. Okay. So that the movie you're referring to, we shot in Austria, and that's a whole another kind of, how do you describe it? Let's just say the Austrians are not afraid to cut in line. Oh, oh. Or whoosh right in front of you. Like you really have to be aggressive. It's a different cultural agreement. It's, skiing is their natural, national sport. Yeah. And so everyone skis. And there were times when you're, because there's a certain etiquette in waiting in the lift line where, you know, we give ourselves a little space in between. There would be some guy would have his ski jammed in between my legs pressed up against my back. And I would look back to give the nonverbal like, hello.
在电影里也是。她能滑雪包和一切。我不太能滑雪包。不。好的。所以你提到的那部电影，我们在奥地利拍摄，那是另一种，你该怎么描述它？这么说吧，奥地利人可不怕插队。哦，哦。或者直接从你面前呼啸而过。就像你真的得很有侵略性。这是一种不同的文化契约。滑雪是他们的自然，国家运动。是的。所以每个人都滑雪。有几次当你，因为在缆车排队时有一定的礼仪，你知道的，我们彼此留出一点空间。会有某个家伙把他的滑雪板塞进我的双腿之间，紧贴着我的背。我会回头用非语言表达，比如，你好。
And this person just looked straight ahead and then keep scooting, like pressing against my shoulder blade. And I thought, oh, this is just the way they do it. That was weird. And the other thing was you'd get to the top of a beautiful mountain riding the gondola. And then there's just cigarette butts everywhere. Really? Yeah, it was so bizarre. Wow.
而这个人只是直视前方，然后继续往前蹭，就像压着我的肩胛骨一样。我想，哦，这只是他们的方式。这太诡异了。还有一件事是，你坐缆车到达美丽的山顶。然后到处都是烟头。真的吗？是的，太离奇了。哇。
You just look out and just this beautiful landscape and then littered with cigarette butts. So I would do. So ski Austria. So I would do you guys know. I'm so sorry. Sorry. I feel this is, is this like a paid commercial for ski Austria? Yes.
你放眼望去，只是这美丽的风景，然后到处都是烟头。所以我就会做。所以去奥地利滑雪。所以我就会做你们知道的。我很抱歉。抱歉。我觉得这是，这就像是奥地利滑雪的付费广告吗？是的。
Were you here today? Is that why you're here? I just have to mention a couple of things. Did you bait me into talking about skiing? If you fly into. Hashtag. Hashtag. Stay at the hotel.
你今天在这儿吗？这就是你来这儿的原因吗？我只是得提几件事。你是在引诱我谈论滑雪吗？如果你飞往。话题。话题。住在酒店。
There was one of the towns, the town that, the, use code, the town that, the, use code, Will 40 for 40% off your first night of day. What happens in Ishkel. stays in Ishkel. Hashtag cigarette butts. Ashty cigarette butts. I don't even know where we are. I don't know where we are. I don't either. I love it. I have something. I read that when you were in college, you worked at a small town television station. Yes. This was just local cable. Oh. Around and about Orange County News. Oh, I love that.
有一个小镇，那个小镇，使用代码，那个小镇，使用代码，Will 40，第一晚可享 40% 的折扣。在伊施格尔发生的事。留在伊施格尔。话题：烟头。烟头。我甚至不知道我们在哪儿。我不知道我们在哪儿。我也不知道。太棒了。我有个事。我读到你在大学时在一个小镇电视台工作。是的。这只是当地的有线电视。哦。奥兰治县新闻周边。哦，我喜欢那个。
Seen by no one. Was this before you had decided to go into acting? Like, was this like maybe I'll do this? Well, I had my degree in sports information. Oh. Real major. You know what? What do you learn? That's like the class I took called Ideas of Mathematics. It was like me in the defensive line of a football team.
没人看。这是在你决定进军演艺圈之前吗？就像，这是在想也许我会做这个吗？嗯，我的专业是体育信息。哦。真正的专业。你知道吗？你学到了什么？就像我选修的那门叫数学概念的课。就像我和橄榄球队的防守锋线在一起。
Oh, right, right. You just talking about ideas of math. Yeah, just ideas. General notions. That was basically sports journalism degree. Okay. So that's kind of where I thought I was going to. That was a more legit way to get into entertainment.
哦，对，对。你只是在谈论数学的概念。是的，只是概念。一般概念。那基本上就是体育新闻学位。好的。所以那是我以为我要去的方向。那是进入娱乐行业的一个更合法的途径。
And so I had my degree, but I was, I didn't really have a job. It's not like I got hired out of college. I moved back home and I started working at this local cable thing. And so I did that for like a year and a half. And I'd heard like people had gotten hired out of there and had, you know, because the whole thing is to put together a tape that you send out. And so while I was doing that, though, I thought, I remember they had really good press credentials to like go to they needed someone to go to the L.A. Rams game.
所以我有学位，但我，我其实没有工作。我不是那种一毕业就被录用的人。我搬回了家，开始在这家地方有线电视机构工作。所以我干了一年半左右。我听说有人从那里被录用过，而且，你知道的，因为整个过程就是制作一份磁带寄出去。不过，当我在做那个的时候，我想，我记得他们有很好的记者证去，他们需要有人去L.A.公羊队的比赛。
And you had press credentials. You could like get on the field and get on the field and like interview the coach and all the stuff like that. They were like, so we need someone to go do this and everyone's hand shot up. And my first thought was like, what day is that? Hmm. Do I really? Oh, I got something on Sunday. Yeah.
而且你有记者证。你可以进入球场，进入球场采访教练以及所有类似的事情。他们说，我们需要有人去干这个，所有人的手都举起来了。我的第一反应是，那天是几号？嗯。我真的需要吗？哦，我周日有事。是的。
Maybe I don't really want to do it. Yeah. And I, it wasn't like, oh, gosh, I need that for my tape, which is what you have to have. Yes. Mine was more like, who can I? I got to bring a friend to operate the camera. Oh, it's going to be a pain. And I thought, oh, that's.
也许我真的不想去。是的。而且，这不像，哦，天哪，我需要那个来做我的磁带，那是你必须拥有的。是的。我的想法更像是，我可以带谁去？我得带个朋友去操作摄像机。哦，这太麻烦了。我想，哦，那。
I can't wear shorts. Right. I thought that's not a good sign. That kind of coincided with, I just started thinking, oh, I'm going to have to try to go for this comedy thing because I keep thinking about doing bits. Doing bits and wanting to do it. And I would go and I would sit at the improv in Irvine and sit in the back of the room at an open mic night
我不能穿短裤。对。我觉得这不是个好兆头。那恰好与，我开始思考，哦，我得试着走喜剧这条路，因为我一直想着做段子。做段子，而且想去做。我会去，我会坐在欧文的即兴喜剧俱乐部，在开放麦之夜坐在房间的后面。
and almost sign my name to the list, but be too afraid and go consecutive weeks and just watch three hours of comedy and sit there and think, well, that person, oh, they're terrible. Yeah. I'm much better than them. They should have set it up like this. Yeah.
并且差点在名单上签下我的名字，但又太害怕了，连续几个星期去，只是看三个小时的喜剧，坐在那里想，嗯，那个人，哦，他们太糟糕了。是的。我比他们好得多。他们应该这样安排。是的。
Yeah. Or, ooh, they're really good. And I would just like kind of see what, and so I was kind of doing that. I started taking my first class at the groundlings. I was taking some acting class. So I was kind of doing all that while I was working at the news station. Mm-hmm. And then the comedy won out.
是的。或者，哦，他们真的很棒。我就会去看看，所以我当时差不多在做那个。我开始在格朗林剧团上我的第一节课。我上了一些表演课。所以我一边在新闻台工作，一边做着所有这些。嗯哼。然后喜剧胜出了。
You found your passion. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. And it was it was that I didn't really want to be a new. I wanted to be Chevy Chase. doing the news. I didn't want to actually be doing the news is what kind of came through.
你找到了你的热情。是的。是的。是的。而且是因为我其实不想成为新闻。我想成为切维·切斯。做新闻。我不是真的想做新闻，这才是内心真实的想法。
I once did a news story. I did a story on there was a team of goats that the city of Laguna Beach would hire to clear all the brush as a way of fire mitigation. Right, right. So I did a story on that. It was not a great piece of journalism at all. Super dry. Like I wish I had copies of these stories. There's about 15 goats here today.
我曾经做过一个新闻故事。我做了一个故事，关于拉古纳海滩市雇佣了一群山羊来清理所有的灌木丛，以此作为防火减灾的一种方式。对，对。所以我做了一个关于那个的故事。这根本不是一篇好的新闻报道。超级枯燥。就像我希望我有这些故事的副本。今天这里大约有15只山羊。
Yeah, yeah. I'm in front of the Laguna Beach. You know, it's like super stiff and this and that. But I noticed when I filmed some of the goats, some of the footage, they looked like they were singing. So I did the story as much of it as there was to tell a story. And then I just added opera music to these goats. It blew the guy who ran the station who was our editor and also the teacher of the class. It was like, that's the job.
是啊，是啊。我在拉古纳海滩前面。你知道，就像超级死板之类的那种。但我注意到当我拍摄一些山羊时，一些镜头，它们看起来像是在唱歌。所以我做了这个故事，把能讲的故事讲了大部分。然后我只是给这些山羊配上了歌剧音乐。这让运营这个电视台的家伙惊艳到了，他既是我们的编辑也是班上的老师。就像，这就是工作。
the way you do a story. You added a little pizzazz. It was hilarious. I was like, it wasn't that old. I just added, yeah. Oh, yeah. And I thought, oh, that's funny. That's, I'm more interested in messing around. I could never do anything in front of a group of people without doing a bit. Okay. And you know, you can't do bits with strangers for the most part. They don't land. Right, right, right, right. But, like, I was in charge of basically, like, the minutes in my sorority. And I would get up. My fraternity was a big stage for me as well. Yes.
你讲故事的方式。你加了一点情调。太搞笑了。我想，它没那么老。我只是加上了，是的。哦，是的。我想，哦，这很有趣。这是，我对胡闹更感兴趣。如果在群人面前，我绝不做点段子就什么也做不了。好的。你知道的，你基本上不能和陌生人开段子。它们不管用。对，对，对，对。但是，就像我基本上负责我姐妹会的会议纪要。我会站起来。我的兄弟会也是我的一个大舞台。是的。
Yeah. So I had to get up and sort of say how the, you know, the pledge dance went and what everyone ate. And I just started doing all these bits. Yeah. And it was like crickets. There were like three gals that laughed. And then then I also offended a few people because I guess they, I did a bit about the chicken dish. And it was a big deal.
是的。所以我不得不站起来，有点像说，你知道，预科生舞会进行得怎么样，大家都吃了什么。然后我开始做所有这些段子。是的。就像蟋蟀叫一样。有大概三个姑娘笑了。然后，然后我还冒犯了几个人，因为我猜他们，我做了一个关于鸡肉菜肴的段子。那是个大事件。
I guess there was a committee that voted on this chicken dish. And they were really pissed off at me. And I, but I just couldn't wait to get up there again the next week and give minutes. But did you slowly win them over in a way? Some, not all. The answer is no. Yeah. But I couldn't wait to get.
我猜有一个委员会投票决定了这道鸡肉菜肴。他们对我很生气。而且我，但我简直等不及下周再站上去做会议记录了。但你慢慢地以某种方式赢得他们了吗？有些，不是全部。答案是没有。是的。但我迫不及待想上去。
I was like, oh, I mean, what am I? I can't get up there. It was your first open mic. I did the same thing. I was our song chairman. Mm-hmm. And so during the chapter of me, there was no, there was no reason for the song chairman to ever speak. But I made.
我就想，哦，我的意思是，我算什么？我不能站在那儿。那是你的第一个开放麦。我也做了同样的事。我是我们的歌曲主席。嗯哼。所以在这个章节中，歌曲主席根本没有理由发言。但我做了。
Once again, we need to hear from the song chairman. I made the song chairman's report. Mm-hmm. And I had Monday night class, so I couldn't be there. So I tape recorded a report. And it became this thing. And they would play it? They would play it.
我们还得听听歌会主席的。我做了歌会主席的报告。嗯。然后我那天晚上有课，所以去不了。于是我录音做了一份报告。结果就成了这回事。他们会放这段录音？他们会放。
And everyone would be like, shh, everyone be quiet. And so they would play the song chairman's report. And I would just, I'd make fun of people in the house. I would do this. I would do that. And became a huge hit. I don't think I became a hit. Yeah.
然后大家就会说：嘘，大家都安静。接着他们就会放歌会主席的报告。而我呢，就会在屋里取笑大家。我会学这个。我会学那个。结果大获成功。我觉得我没有大获成功。对。
Yeah. So. Do you consider Saturday Night Live like your quote-unquote big break? Or was there something before that that really felt like your big break? Yeah, no question. That was definitely. I mean, there was one week when I was still, before I auditioned for Saturday Night Live, there was a week here in L.A.
对。所以。你觉得《周六夜现场》算是你所谓的重大突破吗？还是在此之前有什么事让你真的觉得是重大突破？对，毫无疑问。那绝对算。我是说，在我为《周六夜现场》试镜之前，还是个新人时，有那么一周，我在洛杉矶。
Where I got three jobs in one week. Now, they were all like five and on, they were like one line each. Yeah, but still, that still's huge. I landed on three different sitcoms. That almost was like, I still think of that, you know, and it like got, it was then just after, got my after card from, you know. You're official, you're in the union. And so that was huge.
那周我得到了三份工作。不过，它们都只有五行台词左右，每部戏差不多只有一句台词。对，但那依然很了不起。我同时接到了三部不同的情景喜剧。这几乎就像……我至今还会想起那件事，你知道的，而且差不多就是在拿到了演员工会卡之后。你正式成为公会成员了。所以那意义重大。
And then, of course, yeah, the Saturday Night Live thing was bonkers. How long had you been a struggling actor or an aspiring actor before you landed on Saturday Night Live? Let's see, I would have graduated college in 90 and I got on the show in, I was hired the summer of 95. So about five years, yeah, knocking around. Yeah. Just got your aftercard. Just got, yeah. Yeah, that's pretty cool.
然后，当然了，上《周六夜现场》这件事简直太疯狂了。在加入《周六夜现场》之前，你当了多久苦苦挣扎的演员或怀揣梦想的演员？让我想想，我大概是90年大学毕业，然后我是进节目组……我是在95年夏天被雇用的。所以大概五年吧，到处瞎混。对。刚拿到工会卡。刚拿到，对。对，那挺酷的。
Doing, yeah, doing whatever, like we all were. Yeah. Just kind of like finding any sort of like variety show in L.A. Did you have any odd jobs while you were a struggling actor? I answered phones. Did you really? I answered phones at a real estate auction company. What is that?
做着……对，做着各种杂活，就像我们大家以前那样。对。就像在洛杉矶找任何类型的综艺节目。你当苦苦挣扎的演员时做过什么兼职吗？我接电话。真的吗？我在一家房地产拍卖公司接电话。那是干什么的？
And then I answered phones at a art auction company, which my friend, now wife, Vivica, got me the job. So I was the, I was our appraisal coordinator at Butterfield and Butterfield. You appraised art? No, I typed up the appraisals. You typed it up. Coordinator, coordinator. I coordinated. Right.
然后我在一家艺术品拍卖公司接电话，现在是我的妻子维维卡（Vivica）的朋友帮我找的工作。所以我是……我是伯特菲尔德拍卖行（Butterfield and Butterfield）的估价协调员。你评估艺术品？没有，我把估价结果打出来。你把它打出来。协调员，协调员。我负责协调。对。
The appraisal. Yes. Yes. Okay. Yeah. No, I got hired at S&L and still worked at the auction company for another month. Oh, uh-huh. They weren't going to pay you until the first week of the show.
估价。是的。是的。好吧。对。不，我被S&L（注：原文误指SNL）录用后，还在拍卖行又干了一个月。哦，呃-huh。他们要到节目的第一周才会付你薪水。
And I had bills to pay. But there were other coworkers. I'd be in my cubicle and were like, hey, didn't you get on Saturday Night Live? I'm like, yep, I sure did. I got a courting. I got to get through this stack of appraisals before I leave. We got a fan question from Natalie D. Okay.
而我还有账单要付。但还有其他同事。我坐在隔间里，有人会说，嘿，你不是上了《周六夜现场》吗？我说，对，没错。我有……我得在我离开之前把这堆估价单处理完。我们收到了娜塔莉·D（Natalie D）的一个粉丝提问。好的。
All right. Natalie wanted to know, how did you keep a straight face without laughing, especially in the scene with Ed Helms where you make him eat soap? And Jess Renee asked, if you ever break in scenes. Well, that was going to be my answer to Natalie. I have a superpower of, I'm really good at not breaking. This is what we remember about you. This is what we remember about you. And also, my daughter loves bloopers.
好的，娜塔莉想知道，你怎么能忍住不笑，尤其是和埃德·赫尔姆斯（Ed Helms）对戏时，你让他吃肥皂那场戏？还有杰斯·雷妮（Jess Renee）问，你在拍戏时有没有笑场过。好吧，这就是我要对娜塔莉说的话。我有一种超能力，我真的很擅长忍住不笑。这就是大家对你的记忆。这就是我们对你的记忆。还有，我女儿喜欢NG镜头。
So we end up finding. bloopers and we watch these bloopers of Taledega Nights. Right. And everyone is losing it. And you are like a statue. Right. No, I never, it would only happen like
所以我们最后会去找……NG镜头，然后我们看《塔拉迪加之夜》（Talladega Nights）的NG镜头。对。每个人都笑得前俯后仰。而你就像个雕像一样。对。不，我从来……这种情况大概一年才发生……
twice a year. Yeah. Unlike Saturday Live or something. And a lot of times, though, there are times when I can tell I'm breaking, but no one else can tell. Right, right. So I hide it really well.
两次。对。不像在《周六夜现场》或者别的节目里。而且很多时候，虽然有些时候我知道自己笑场了，但别人看不出来。对，对。所以我藏得很好。
I could tell, not that you were breaking, but that you were genuinely surprised when Ed put the soap in his mouth, because that wasn't scripted and it was real soap. And I think you just improvised for him to try the soap. And then when he did, you can see your face. You're like, hey. It felt like you were doing just like a prank on him.
我看得出来，倒不是说你笑场了，而是当埃德把肥皂放进嘴里时，你真的很吃惊，因为那不是剧本里写的，而且那是真肥皂。我想你只是即兴让他尝尝肥皂。然后他照做时，你能看到你的表情。你就像是，嘿。感觉你就像是在对他搞恶作剧。
Like do this thing. Like there were all these scripted things, absurd things you were going to ask him to do. And you're like, how about eat the soap? And it felt like a personal challenge. And Ed took you up on it. And the look in your eyes is a little bit like, whoa, well. Okay. That's so funny.
就像做这件事。就像有所有这些剧本里的、荒谬的事情你要让他去做。然后你说：要不吃块肥皂怎么样？感觉像是个个人挑战。而埃德接受了你的挑战。你眼神里的表情有点像：哇，好吧。好吧。太搞笑了。
Yeah. One question before we take a break. Do you remember the stunt gone wrong in the warehouse? We were talking about when stunts can go wrong. Yes. We got to talk to Greg about it. We got to talk to Randy Cordray, who was our production manager at the time. They all just want to say sorry again for basically just catapulting you.
对。在休息前还有一个问题。你还记得仓库里那个出了事故的特技吗？我们刚才在讨论特技什么时候会出问题。是的。我们得和格雷格（Greg）谈谈这件事。我们得和兰迪·科德雷（Randy Cordray）谈谈，他当时是我们的制片经理。他们所有人只是想再次为基本上……把你像投石机一样。
Catapulting you into a basketball hoop. No, I don't remember it. You're thinking of something else? Oh, no. I just thought you meant the... Like, story-wise. Story-wise. You don't remember when we actually almost like...
把你像投石机一样弹射到一个篮球框里道歉。不，我不记得了。你想的是别的什么吧？哦，不。我只是以为你指的是……从剧情角度来说。剧情角度来说。你不记得我们当时差点……
No. ...gave you a real concussion? They had the pulley and they... Did it go? They are going to be so relieved that you don't remember this. Oh, my gosh. They have carried this around for a year. It is haunted us, Will.
不。……真的给你造成脑震荡了吗？他们用了滑轮，然后他们……真的吗？他们听到你不记得这事一定会松一大口气的。哦，天哪。他们背负这件事已经一年了。这折磨死我们了，威尔。
Because I remembered when I revisited the episode going, oh, that's right. We do the thing. I go for the basketball dunk and it falls on me, but it's all. off camera, da-da-da. But no, I don't remember. Oh, did something go alive? I don't remember. So what happened, Greg said, is they designed this pulley thing.
因为我回想起那集的时候才想起来，哦，对。我们做了那个特技。我去扣篮，然后篮框砸在我身上，但这全都是……镜头拍不到的，哒哒哒。但没有，我不记得了。哦，有什么是实景拍的吗？我不记得了。所以发生了什么，格雷格说，他们设计了这个滑轮装置。
And Greg said, just as he looked at it, he thought the physics were off on it. And they put you in it. And the first take, they were, as you jumped, these guys were going to pull this thing. And then you were going to go up a little bit. And the first time, they didn't quite get you there. Yeah. And they were like, okay, well, do it again. You guys, we got to pull harder.
格雷格说，他刚看了一眼，就觉得那里的物理原理不对劲。然后他们把你放了上去。第一条的时候，他们打算在你起跳时拉动这个装置。然后你会稍微往上升一点。第一次，他们没完全把你拉到位。对。然后他们就想，好吧，再来一次。伙计们，我们得用力拉。
So the second time you went to do the jump and they yanked it and you went flying into the backboard. And I guess you got like a big cut on your knee. No. Yes. And we were all just like mortified. We were mortified. How do I not have a memory of this? I don't.
所以在第二次你准备起跳时，他们猛地一拉，你就飞了出去，撞到了篮板上。我猜你的膝盖好像划了个大口子。没有。有这回事。而我们所有人都吓坏了。我们吓坏了。我怎么可能对这事一点记忆都没有？我没有。
You probably blocked it out because of the trauma. And then they were like, you don't have to do it again. Don't even worry about it. And you're like, no, no, no. I got one more. Let's do one more. And then they got that one. That was it.
你可能是因为创伤把它给选择性遗忘了。然后他们说，你不用再拍了。连想都别想。而你说，不，不，不。我还有一个。让我们再拍一个。然后他们就拍了那个。就是这样。
The only thing I do remember about that sequence is editorially, I said the funniest, strongest, kind of darkest thing is that DeAngel is dead. I do remember you pitching that. And I was like, that's the funniest thing. That's like the funniest way. We kill you. Yes. But then they're like, okay, just for safety, let's just shoot this thing. And I was like, oh, this is going in.
关于那个序列，我唯一记得的是，从剪辑的角度来看，我说过最有趣、最有力、甚至有点黑暗的话，那就是德安杰洛（DeAngelo）死了。我确实记得你提出了这个点子。我当时就觉得，那是最好笑的事。那是最搞笑的方式。我们杀了你。是的。但后来他们说，好吧，为了安全起见，我们就拍这个吧。我当时想，哦，这个要剪进去。
Yeah. Where I'm walking through the office with my head bandaged. Oh, no, I know. I laughed through all your takes. You see me laughing. Fans just pointed it out. They're like, Angela, you're not even. I did see you on that one.
对。我头上缠着绷带走过办公室的那场戏。哦，不，我懂。我在你所有的镜头里都笑场了。你能看到我在笑。粉丝们刚才还指出来。他们说，安吉拉，你甚至都没……我确实看到你在那场戏里笑了。
You know why? Because, okay, here's the thing. First of all, whatever, you're the funniest person on the planet. There's that. But no, no. No. But then on top of it, you give someone who is so flippin funny, gibberish words, and then you never did them the same. So every time I would get used to you being like face-nice-nature.
你知道为什么吗？因为，好吧，情况是这样的。首先，不管怎样，你是地球上最搞笑的人。这倒确实。但是，不，不。没有。但最重要的是，你给了一个超级无敌搞笑的人一堆毫无意义的胡话，而且你每次说的都不一样。所以每次当我习惯了你那种一本正经的温和表情时……
Then the next time I'd be like, ha-da-da-ha. I was like, I can't. I can't. But that was the only thing I do really remember. So that's crazy. remember cutting my leg open, but I do remember going, oh, I wish they would have just killed me off. That'd be so funny. Yeah.
然后下一次我就会觉得，哈哈哒哒哈哈。我想，我受不了。我受不了。但那是我唯一真正记得的事情。所以这太疯狂了。我不记得把腿划破了，但我确实记得当时想的是，哦，我真希望他们直接把我写死。那会多搞笑啊。对。
Like whatever happened to DeAngel. There was a, in the shooting draft, there was. I guess it was too dark. It was too dark for the guys. Because we have the shooting drafts. There was a scene where the ambulance is taking you away. Right. And Daryl says to Andy, is he going to be okay?
就像德安杰洛后来怎么了。在拍摄初稿里，有一个……我猜这太黑暗了。对大伙来说太黑暗了。因为我们有拍摄初稿。有个场景是救护车把你拉走。对。然后达里尔（Daryl）对安迪（Andy）说，他会没事吧？
And Andy goes, I don't, they said no. That's what I'm saying. It's so funny. Yes. That would have been so good. They said no. No. Boy, how did I not remember getting slammed into the backboard?
安迪说，我不知道，他们说不行。这就是我说的。太搞笑了。是的。那本来会非常棒。他们说不行。不。天哪，我怎么会不记得自己被猛撞到篮板上呢？
I don't know. Wow. They are going to be so relieved. I mean, I'm going to call on this afternoon. I know. I'm like, guys, Will has no memory. They're going to be like, what's his problem? We asked Greg about it.
我不知道。哇。他们一定会大大松一口气的。我是说，我今天下午就要打电话说这事。我知道。我会说，伙计们，威尔完全不记得了。他们会觉得，他有什么毛病？我们问过格雷格了。
Did he not? We asked Greg about it. And the first thing he said was, oh, I still think about that constantly. Really? Yeah. Oh, please tell him. until this moment. And even now, I'm not picturing it happening.
他没说吗？我们问过格雷格了。他说的第一句话是，哦，我到现在还一直在想那件事。真的吗？对。哦，请告诉他。直到这一刻。甚至现在，我脑海里都没有浮现出当时发生的情景。
Wow. Oh, I'm texting Greg. Yeah. Okay, well, let's take a break. And when we come back, we have a regular guy quiz for you. Yeah, we just ask you questions that a regular guy would answer. Okay. We'll see if you're a regular guy.
哇。哦，我要给格雷格发信息。对。好吧，那我们先休息一下。等我们回来，我们要为你进行一个“普通人问答”。对，我们就是问你一些普通人会回答的问题。好的。我们来看看你是不是个普通人。
All right, Will, we're back from our break. We're going to give you the regular guy questions. These are real, like, hard-hitting stuff. Yeah, I know. If you're ready, this is the part where... It'll prove if I'm a regular guy. Yeah. I can feel it.
好了，威尔，我们休息回来了。我们要给你出“普通人问题”。这些都是真正的、那种直击灵魂的问题。对，我知道。如果你准备好了，这就是……这能证明我是不是个普通人。对。我能感觉到。
Okay. Question number one. Everyone's really crowded around the windows of the studio. I know. We got a few succulents looking in. What do you eat for breakfast? I usually eat, I love this Ezekiel's brand cereal. Mm-hmm.
好的。问题一。大家都围在演播室的窗户外面。我知道。有几棵多肉植物在往里看。你早餐吃什么？我通常吃，我特别喜欢以西结（Ezekiel）品牌的麦片。嗯。
Is it like a musli sort of thing? It's kind of like a more of like a grape nuts, you think. Okay. Is that every morning? Are you the same breakfast every day? Some. Not necessarily. Oh, you mix it up.
那是类似什锦麦片之类的东西吗？它有点像格雷普纳茨（Grape-Nuts）麦片，你懂的。好吧。每天都吃这个吗？你每天的早餐都一样吗？差不多。不一定。哦，你会换着吃。
I mix it up. Okay. Okay. Where's your protein in the morning? It's in the cereal. Okay. I'm just checking. Yeah.
我换着吃。好吧。好吧。你早上的蛋白质在哪？在麦片里。好吧。我只是确认一下。对。
All right. Number two, what is one of your favorite places you visited in the United States? One of, well, really? Yeah. I love New York City. Duh. Who doesn't? It's a great place.
好的，第二题，你在美国去过的地方里，最喜欢的一个是哪里？其中一个，真的吗？对。我喜欢纽约市。废话。谁不喜欢？那是个好地方。
I love it. I want to retire there. It's always surprising to me. how you rediscover that city every time you visit. That is true. You're speaking to my soul. Right? There's just so many nooks and crannies and a new place here in a Zda and this museum.
我爱死那儿了。我想在那里退休。我总是感到很惊讶。每次你去的时候，怎么能重新发现这座城市的美。确实如此。说到我心坎里了。对吧？那里有太多大街小巷，这里有个新地方，那里有个什么博物馆。
And it blows my mind. I love it. I blows my mind. But I also just went to Portland. Portland, it's a little hidden gym. Maybe not so hidden now, but Portland's great. Yeah. Have you been?
这让我大开眼界。我太喜欢了。这让我大开眼界。但我最近也去了波特兰。波特兰，那是个有点被低估的宝藏地方。也许现在已经不算隐秘了，但波特兰真的很棒。对。你去过吗？
No. I love Portland. I love the Oregon Coast. Great restaurants, little coffee places. like cool bike paths and walking trails and so green a big enough of a city feel to it if you need that but then really great neighborhoods. In general, are you more city or more like rural kind of like do you like a kind of like hiking kind of outdoorsy thing or do you like city?
没有。我喜欢波特兰。我喜欢俄勒冈海岸。很棒的餐厅、小咖啡馆、酷炫的自行车道和步行小径，而且到处都是绿色，既有足够大的城市感，又有非常棒的街区。总的来说，你更喜欢城市还是乡村？比如你喜欢徒步这种户外活动，还是喜欢城市？
I can really kind of adjust wherever I am. But my wife's definitely more city. And I love cities too. So I'll go city. Okay. Okay. Okay. Okay. What was the make and model of your first car? It was a 1969 powder blue VW bug.
无论我在哪里，我基本上都能适应。但我太太绝对更喜欢城市。我也很喜欢城市。所以我会选城市。好吧。好吧。好吧。好吧。你的第一辆车的品牌和型号是什么？那是1969年粉蓝色的大众甲壳虫。
Oh. Do you wish you still had it? It's kind of amazing. I had a COVID midlife purchase where I bought a 61 VW bus with the 23 windows around the top. Yeah, yeah, yeah. Yes. Like surf green, blue with white, it was like beautiful. but I just sold it again because it made me too nervous to drive it because it was in like mint condition. Right. It was too special. It was too special. Yeah. But then I'd feel guilty about not driving it. And then I felt guilty about when I drove it because I didn't want to get dinged and I just couldn't handle. It was a stressful purchase. Exactly. I don't think I'll ever be like a car guy that way.
哦。你希望现在还留着它吗？这挺神奇的。我在新冠期间遭遇了一场中年购物冲动，买了一辆61年的大众巴士，车顶四周有23扇窗户。对，对，对。是的。就像冲浪绿，带白色的蓝色，简直美极了。但我刚把它又卖了，因为它让我开车时太紧张了，因为它是崭新的状态。对。太特别了。太珍贵了。对。但后来我对不驾驶它感到内疚。然后当我驾驶它时我又感到内疚，因为我不想让它有任何磕碰，我实在应付不来。那是一次压力重重的购物。没错。我想我这辈子都不会成为那种真正的车迷。
Yeah. I get it. So regular guy. Pretty regular guy. Okay. This one hits close to home with me. How many emails are your inbox? Do you keep a tidy box or do you let them put? file up? Very tidy. Okay. Very tight. I answer stuff. I cleared the decks right away. How many do I have?
对。我懂。所以算是个普通人。挺普通的。好的。这一个和我的生活挺贴近的。你的收件箱里有多少封电子邮件？你是个保持收件箱整洁的人，还是让它们堆积如山？非常整洁。好吧。非常整洁。我会回复各种事情。我马上就把事情处理干净。我有多少封？
1700. Yeah. How does that make you feel when you read that Angela has 1,700 emails? Does that? I can't handle it. It bothers me. I can't handle it. I don't like it when she shows it to me.
1700封。对。当你看到安吉拉有1700封未读邮件时，你作何感想？会吗？我受不了。这让我抓狂。我受不了。我讨厌她把这个给我看。
It gives me heart palpitations. Sorry. Listen, I'm chipping away at it. Yeah. Next one. If you are in charge of cooking dinner, what is your go-to dish? I couldn't even say. What?
这让我心跳加速。对不起。听着，我在一点点清理呢。对。下一个。如果你负责做晚饭，你的拿手菜是什么？我甚至都说不出来。什么？
Come on. I don't ever cook dinner. Who cooks? Viv does. Oh, well, that's good. You're lucky. You have a person who does the dinners. My husband always cooks.
拜托。我从来不做晚饭。谁做饭？维v（Viv）做。哦，那挺好的。你真幸运。你有个包办晚饭的人。我丈夫总是做饭。
Really? Yeah, I don't cook. I need to, I need to. I need to get a dish. We need a go-to dish. I know. I don't have one. You should take a cooking class together.
真的吗？对，我不会做饭。我需要，我得学一个。我得有一道拿手菜。我知道。我没有。你们应该一起去上个烹饪课。
Get a go-to dish. Oh, my God. There should be a cooking school called go-to-ditch. Yeah. Because you go to learn, but you also go to dish. Yes, hey, hey, did you hear about this? Oh, my God. That's too much Parmesan.
学道拿手菜。哦，天哪。应该有一所烹饪学校叫“拿手菜学校”。对。因为你去学习，但你也是去八卦（dish）。是的，嘿，嘿，你听说了这个吗？哦，天哪。帕玛森奶酪放太多了。
No way. I got wrapped up in the dish. Now I have to focus back on this dish. That's actually pretty great. Go-to dish. What's your go-to board game? Do you have a family board game? The go-to game right now is celebrity.
绝不可能。我刚才光顾着聊八卦了。现在我得把注意力重新集中在这个菜（dish）上。这其实挺棒的。“拿手菜”（Go-to dish）。你最拿手的桌游是什么？你们家有什么家庭桌游吗？现在最拿手的是名人猜词游戏。
Mm-hmm. Yeah, love it. So the kids, we started doing it on ski trips, and they go crazy. They love trying to trip us up with, you know, YouTubers and people like that. Oh, forget it. And we're trying to act out. Yeah, pop culture people that we don't know anymore.
嗯-hmm。对，超喜欢。所以孩子们，我们是从滑雪旅行时开始玩这个的，他们玩疯了。他们特别喜欢用各种网红和类似的人来给我们挖坑。哦，算了吧。而我们则努力去模仿。对，那些我们已经不认识的流行文化人物。
And it cracks them up. But then we get them back with... The oldies. Martin Van Buren. We were playing with my family and I was trying. I had Jennifer Aniston. Yeah. And my sister Janet was like, I don't know who that is.
这让他们笑得前仰后合。但随后我们会用……老古董来反击他们。马丁·凡·布伦（Martin Van Buren）。我和家人一起玩的时候，我一直在努力。我抽到了詹妮弗·安妮斯顿（Jennifer Aniston）。对。我妹妹珍妮（Janet）就说，我不知道那是谁。
I was like, well, yes, you do. You do. Nope, don't know. I'm like, oh, my God. Okay. How early do you get to the airport? before a flight? I am, I'm like, I'm pretty much a rule follower.
我说，好吧，你当然知道。你明明知道。不，不知道。我说，哦，天哪。好吧。你一般提前多久去机场？赶航班？我，我基本上是个遵守规则的人。
I, like the two hour thing. But here's my rule, though. If I'm late, I don't run. I don't run. I don't run to catch that flight. So what happens? Do you walk slowly? I, almost to punish.
我，喜欢提前两个小时左右。但我的原则是，如果我迟到了，我不跑。我不跑。我才不会为了赶那趟航班而跑。那会怎么样？你慢慢走吗？我，几乎就像是为了惩罚……
What is great rule? Because it won't be, I'm not the reason we're late. I'll just leave it at that. Oh. So I'm not going to have to... But I'll slow walk it. Uh-huh. If everyone wants to be this late, we're going to miss our flight.
这是什么绝佳原则？因为我不会是那个让我们迟到的人。我就直说了。哦。所以我才不会……但我会慢吞吞地走。呃-huh。如果大家都想这么迟，那我们就要错过航班了。
There's consequences. There's consequences. Right. Get your act together. Let's be ready. That'll teach them. Plan better. I don't know why.
这是有后果的。这是有后果的。对。振作起来。准备好吧。这能给他们上一课。计划周全点。我不知道为什么。
I don't want to punish, but I do. It's a teaching moment. All right. Well, Cynthia R. asked, what was your favorite sitcom or cartoon as a kid? Oh, I had so many. I mean, I lived in the world of sitcoms, you know. Just like, oh, wouldn't it be great to be on the castle? Wouldn't it be great to live on the love boat?
我不是故意要惩罚，但我确实这么做了。这是一个教学时刻。好吧。辛西娅·R（Cynthia R.）问，你小时候最喜欢的情景喜剧或动画片是什么？哦，我有太多了。我是说，我生活在情景喜剧的世界里，你知道的。就像，哦，能在《爱的航程》（Love Boat）上该有多好？能在《爱情船》（The Love Boat）上生活该有多好？
Yes. Right? Or Fantasy Island? Fantasy Island. I mean, please. That ABC, they had a little run there between Happy Days, Laverne and Shirley, Tuesday nights. Forget about it. How cool to just be able to hit a jukebox and the music.
对。对吧？或者《梦幻岛》（Fantasy Island）？《梦幻岛》。我是说，拜托。美国广播公司（ABC），他们在周二晚上从《欢乐时光》（Happy Days）、《拉旺与雪莉》（Laverne and Shirley）开始，有一段很棒的黄金档。别提了。能够随意拍一下点唱机，音乐就响起来，那有多酷啊。
Like, what a fun character bit. How cool to have your office in the. the men's bathroom. Yeah. That's true. I forgot about that. All right. Our last regular guy question for you, Will, is do you have a hobby?
这是一个多有趣的搞笑桥段。把办公室设在……男洗手间里，这有多酷啊。对，确实。我都把这茬忘了。好的。我们对你的最后一个普通人问题，威尔，是你有爱好吗？
I get asked this. Do you really? And I never have an answer. I don't collect stamps or baseball cards or anything like that. What is, if I did have a hobby? Big finish here. Big finish. I don't know if I have a habitual thing.
经常有人问我这个。真的吗？而我从来没有答案。我不收集邮票、棒球卡或者类似的东西。如果我真的有爱好，那会是什么？重磅收尾来了。重磅收尾。我不知道我有没有什么习惯性的东西。
Right. Yeah. That's... Mine is, I was thinking about this. I'm like, what's my hobby? Really? Like, I love to go for a walk every day. And I love, I have a lot of hummingbird feeders.
对。对。那是……我的爱好是，我一直在想这个。我想，我的爱好是什么？真的吗？比如，我喜欢每天去散步。我喜欢，我有很多蜂鸟喂食器。
Okay. Because I live the sexy life. Yeah, no kidding. So. I do genuinely love driving my kids to school. But that's not a hobby. That's so cute. This is not a hobby because I don't do it consistently enough, but we have a chicken coop.
好吧。因为我过着性感的生活。对，不开玩笑。所以。我确实由衷地喜欢开车送我的孩子上学。但那不是爱好。太可爱了。这不算爱好，因为我做得不够频繁，但我们有一个鸡舍。
So we have chickens. Oh. And I love, it's, there's a real serenity to going out there and clean. cleaning the chicken coop. Kind of talk to the chickens a little bit. There's a little compost section to it. I kind of make sure they have fresh, you know. But it's not like I do that every two days.
所以我们养了鸡。哦。我喜欢，去那里打扫鸡舍有一种真正的宁静感。跟鸡聊聊天什么的。那里还有一个小堆肥区。我得确保它们有新鲜的，你知道的。但也不是说我每两天就做一次。
Right. Right. I'll take it. Okay, that's my hobby. It doesn't have to be it often. It's just a thing that brings you joy. Yeah. Sorry. What are you sorry for?
对。对。我认了。好吧，这就是我的爱好。它不一定得经常做。它只是能给你带来快乐的事情。对不起。你为什么道歉？
I feel like this was. No one's, everyone's going to remember how bad the podcast ended. Stop it. I have a good ending. You're going to get so many letters. No, no. By the way. By the way, Farrell, dud city.
我觉得这个……没有人，大家都会记住这个播客是以多糟糕的方式结束的。住手。我有一个很好的结局。你会收到超多信件的。不，不。顺便说一句。顺便说一句，法瑞尔（Ferrell），烂透了。
Steve, Steve was like. Dud City hashtag Dud City USA. When we did Steve's regular guy questions, all we did was make Steve feel like he was the most boring person on her. He was like, oh my God. Why did Nancy marry me? Like, I'm hearing myself back and I've never felt worse about myself. This is why we asked to take the picture at the top. Maybe we like to leave people.
史蒂夫（Steve），史蒂夫就像是……烂透了，美国烂透了俱乐部。当我们做史蒂夫的普通人问题时，我们所做的就是让史蒂夫觉得他是这里最无聊的人。他当时就像，哦，天哪。南希为什么会嫁给我？听着自己的回答，我对自己的感觉从来没有这么糟糕过。这就是为什么我们在开始时要求拍照。也许我们喜欢让人陷入……
And like a shame spiral. It was prophetic. We might need to change the name from regular guy quiz to just like want to feel shitty? What to really feel? Now I got to get a hobby. So I can literally answer this question. We want to thank you so much for coming today, Will. And I wanted to end with such this sweet note from a fan from Maxie B.
陷入自我怀疑的漩涡。这太有预见性了。我们可能需要把“普通人问答”改个名字，叫“想感觉自己糟透了吗？”。想真正感觉……现在我得去找个爱好。这样我才能直面回答这个问题。非常感谢你今天能来，威尔。我想以粉丝马克西·B（Maxie B）写的一段如此温馨的话来结束。
Maxie said this. My mom and I adore watching Will Ferrell movies together and cracking up. My mom just turned 70 in January, and we began talking about the thing that all kids dread talking about with their parents, the funeral arrangements. She wants cremation and a big party to celebrate her life, which I love, but she had the cutest request that she knows won't be able to happen. She asked me to please hire Will Ferrell to sing her favorite song, Dust in the Wind, at her party. I just think that is the sweetest thing, and I would love it. for Will to know how much he means to us and our family. He has kept us going through hard times, all my love, Maxie B. That is, isn't that so sweet? I just think that's like, you bring so much
马克西是这么说的：我和我妈妈超级喜欢一起看威尔·法瑞尔的电影并笑得前俯后仰。我妈妈在一月份刚满70岁，我们开始聊起所有孩子都害怕跟父母聊的事情——葬礼安排。她希望火化并举办一场盛大的派对来庆祝她的一生，我非常喜欢这个主意，但她有一个最可爱的要求，她知道这可能无法实现。她让我务必请威尔·法瑞尔在她的派对上唱她最喜欢的歌《随风而逝》（Dust in the Wind）。我只是觉得这是最贴心的事情，我希望威尔能知道他对我们和我们的家庭意味着什么。他在我们经历艰难时期时一直支撑着我们，送上我所有的爱，马克西·B。这，是不是超级温馨？我只是觉得……你通过你的工作、你的喜剧，以及仅仅作为你自己，给人们带来了巨大的安慰。当你在那个过渡时期来到办公室时，你给我们办公室带来了巨大的安慰。对。所以，我的意思是，这就是我们为什么要这么做。这就是，我的意思是，这就是作为一名艺术家的意义。这，简直不能再好了。更好。更棒。她妈妈的幽默感太有趣了。她想要火化，还想让你唱《随风而逝》。我爱死这位女士了。
comfort to people with what you do, with your comedy, and just with who you are, you brought so much comfort to us on the office when you came in during that transition time. Right. So, I mean, that's why we do it. That's why, I mean, that's what being an artist is. That's, couldn't be nice. Nicer. Nicer. And what a fun sense of humor her mom has. She wants to be cremated and wants you to sing dust in the wind. I love this woman.
对吧？我知道。我知道。我无言以对。我们超级崇拜你。真的。每次看到你我都总是那么开心。当我们碰到你时，你就是那种真正的好人。
Right? I know. I know. I'm speechless. We adore you. We really do. I'm just always so happy when I see you. And when we run into you, you're just one of the good guys.
你是个顶好的人。谢谢你们，伙计们。谢谢你们。我不知道。我这就上车开车去。对。让所有的……赞美把我淹没吧。
You're one of the good ones. Thanks, you guys. Thank you. I don't know. I'm going to just going to drive in my car now. Yeah. And just let all of the. Just praise wash over me.
接受它。好吧。太有趣了。太有趣了。好了，在我们开始为期两周的假期之前。伙计们，你们知道我有多喜欢过生日。你们知道我有多喜欢庆祝生日。好吧，我们的日程安排这几周有点古怪。
Own it. Okay. That was so much fun. So fun. Okay, before we leave for our two week break. You guys, you know how much I love birthdays. You know how much I love celebrating them. Well, we have had a wonky few weeks with scheduling.
我们发生了太多事情。而在詹娜的生日周期间，我们没能给她庆祝生日。但是你知道吗？庆祝生日永远都不嫌晚。老实说，我很惊讶。这太棒了。安吉拉，你知道的，我在纽约市独自度过了我的生日，因为我在拍《贱女孩》（Mean Girls）。我知道。
We've had a lot going on. And we were not able to celebrate Jenna's birthday when it was her birthday week. But you know what? It is never too late for birthday week. I am honestly, I am surprised. This is so nice. Angela, you know, I spent my birthday by myself in New York City because I was shooting mean girls. I know.
而且那确实有点艰难。我得说我的家人太棒了。李（Lee）把生日礼物藏在我的行李箱里让我打开。我们在我离开前庆祝了一点，在我回家后又庆祝了一点。但我们没能在播客里庆祝。所以女士们，坐好吧。我有些好东西要送给你们。哦，天哪。科迪（Cody）和萨姆（Sam），我要把淋浴间的推拉门打开了。卡西（Cassie），我很遗憾你今天不在，但我们会给你留一些的。
And it was a little tough. I'll say my family was wonderful. Lee hid birthday presents in my suitcase for me to open. And we celebrated a little before I left, a little bit after I got home. But we have not been able to celebrate here on the pod. So ladies, sit back. I got some stuff coming your way. Oh my gosh. Cody and Sam, I'm opening up the shower screen door thing. Cassie, I'm sad you're not here today, but we'll save some for you.
好的。我把这些都藏在房间的角落里了。我完全不知道这里有这个。好吧。首先，这是一个礼物，你一打开就会发现，这是你之前说过你想要的东西。好的。好的。我之前说过我想要的东西。我想要这个。这是一个带灯的放大镜化妆镜。这样我就可以修眉毛了。它可以把任何东西放大三倍。我这49岁的眼睛。非常谢谢你。等等，我得给你拍张照。
Okay. I had this all hidden in the corner of the room. I had no idea this was here. Okay. So first of all, this is a gift that the minute you open it, it's something you said you wanted. Okay. Okay. Something I said I wanted. I want this. This is the lighted magnification mirror. So I can tweez my eyebrows. And it magnifies three times the magnitude of whatever. My 49-year-old eyes. Thank you so much. Wait, I have to take your picture with it.
好的。下一位女士，我去了一家我最喜欢的面包店，给你买了一份带糖针的无麸质布朗尼。哦，无麸质甜点。哦，我太喜欢了。好的，希望它们在车里没有被晃散架。哦，它们太完美了。谢谢你，女士。
Okay. And next lady, I went to one of my favorite bakeries, and I got you gluten-free brownies with sprinkles. Ooh, gluten-free dessert. Oh, I love it. Okay, I hope they didn't get tossed around in the car. Oh, they're perfect. Thank you, lady.
生日快乐。谢谢你们。再见，伙计们。感谢收听《办公室女士》。《办公室女士》是奥德赛（Audyssey）出品的节目，由詹娜·费舍尔和安吉拉·金斯利制作。我们的资深制作人是马特·比格尔（Matt Beagle），音频工程师是萨姆·基弗（Sam Kiefer）。奥德赛的执行制作人是莉亚·里斯·丹尼斯（Leah Reese Dennis）。
Birthday. Thank you. Bye, you guys. Thank you for listening to Office Ladies. Office Ladies is a presentation of Odyssey and is produced by Jenna Fisher and Angela Kinsey. Our senior producer is Matt Beagle and our audio engineer is Sam Kiefer. Odyssey's executive producer is Leah Reese Dennis.
《办公室女士》由比尔·舒尔茨（Bill Shultz）混音和母带处理。我们的主题曲是克里德·布拉顿（Creed Bratton）的《鲁珀特里》（Ruppertry）。这集还没有评论。点击剧本中的任意句子即可发表评论。
Office Ladies was mixed and mastered by Bill Shultz. Our theme song is Ruppertry by Creed Bratton. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
Office Ladies由比尔·舒尔茨进行混音和母带处理。我们的主题曲是克里德·布拉顿创作的《Ruppertry》。本集目前还没有评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。